hello I've been thinking as normal of a
few things about Aikido and Us in
general
and I wanted to talk today about
categorizing different things
um there's technical that most people
are
absorbed in and really most people are
absorbed in this for most of their
Aikido life so so it appears when I put
out
these talking films in general in
YouTube they do get uh
good views but the ones that you put out
dynamically doing throws or any form of
dynamic work
they get three times the
the hits you know people are more
interested in watching the fun of it
rather than analyzing
and listening to what makes that the
cogs go
round for you to perform better
techniques
so
to categorize it we've got the
techniques that everybody
from day one starts to analyze Sony
works out over the years gets better at
it stronger fitter finds more economic
ways of doing it
and this is really good
but one should be done a long time I
have
you start to think you know what are the
benefits what what are the pluses that
I'm getting out of doing Aikido
not all Scrolls do do weapons but I'm a
great believer in the book he was a
system because to me weapons make so
much difference to
um
correctness of angle body angles you
have to blend with your partner
you know precisely at the right time it
can't just be
like if there's no weapons then you
don't understand Panic or fear in the
same way as perhaps when you're a
beginner you understand Panic somebody
goes to grab your strikely quick and you
you panic
but after some time uh you you overcome
that easily with the weapons you never
you can still be surprised even when
you're an advanced student
so to me the the weapons are very
important part so we've got normal
taijitsu technical bodies one-on-one on
one or multiples we've got book what's a
one-on-one
or again multiples then you've got
variations of
Canon Ken or Ken against Joe and vice
versa Sergio against Joe
so these are all segments and if you
wanted to write a list of the things
that you you do in like you don't what
you like some will come out more on top
than the other
I remember things that cytosensi said
and he said and it's in other films he
said Tony everybody should have a a ghee
um
and if you've got your own dojo
then you need
to make sure that you've got a can a Joe
and above all mirrors
and he made a big thing about this he
said
if you look in the mirror while you're
doing techniques you're about to see
your whether you're correct or not but
this was mainly when doing weapons
because you can check yourself you're
one-to-one between you and the mirror
really and you can check yourself out
it's very difficult I do know some
exhibitionist teachers who as they're
throwing they're actually looking I've
watched them and they actually look in
the mirror while they're throwing to see
how good they look
uh sad people
uh my opinion
so then you go on to
uh I don't know if he said it or whether
I created this myself but you shouldn't
film yourself either teaching or
training if the teacher will let you
film yourself once or twice in a year
every year
most people don't like looking at
themselves well where are you know
you'll be your own self-critic
if you do this then you'll be able to
look at your postures your weaknesses
your your stronger points and just
ignore the stronger points to a certain
degree if you're looking to improve
always look for the weaknesses but don't
be yourself unmentually about the
weaknesses look at them as strengths
because if you've spotted it then it's a
strength because you can start working
on correcting it
so how do we correct it well what I've
done over the years even though
cytosensi was my teacher for 27 years
and I've often spoke about this he
couldn't teach me everything because
perhaps I couldn't see everything he was
trying to teach me
so I would look at others I would either
look up
videos you know on YouTube of different
Masters I remember learning my up white
posture more from Chiba sensei
and then I saw how much cheaper sense it
looked like oh Sensei when he was doing
his upright postures
um I learned my Aroma Nagi of Yamada
Sensi and sadly now passed away
and his ramanagi is totally different to
any wild woman Aggie but I saw a flow I
saw something where you engage with the
other person and the timing of when to
throw
initio Scentsy
was a very much a weapons man aido a
master as well as an Aikido master and I
like his preciseness
he looks as if he was doing a lot of his
Michael jerky type of size work but it
was direct but it was more of the body
angles
that I liked you know he would Escape
just at the right moment
sheoda Kozo shioda he was an amazing
character very small for Japanese but he
could call upon vast amounts of power
an instant and so I've been working
mentally on what I call the power of the
mind and I get a lot of people looking
at my energy
uh films a lot of people say rubbish
they criticize it but
I I personally know that we have to find
that if we want to get closer to what oh
sensei
was doing in his own Aikido
so
if you don't have the advantage of
one-to-one mirrors in your dojo whether
you're a student or teacher
and you don't like doing the weapons
then
you like to hide it soon or if you like
all of them then I suggest you ask or
teacher if you're a student or if you
are a teacher film yourself twice a year
look at what you want to work on and
slowly work on it
now to get to the main point of this
film is
I observe myself a lot
and over the years criticize myself a
lot and I realized that reading books on
non-martial Arts more about people who
give theirselves a hard time in life and
become and they're anti you know they're
depressives or
depressive people and some people are
getting a very bad state to the point of
suicide
now
if you're in a thinker like I believe I
am
then we can persecute ourselves a lot
but we can also look at the finer detail
of what we're looking for we might not
know what we're looking for
but we can we can search and search
hoping that we'll get an answer to help
whatever this thing we're looking for
and sometimes we don't know it
uh how to open doors and we sometimes
get answers
that we're not really asking the
question for we don't know what we're
looking for not someone get an answer to
something that will make sense
so
I noticed that um when watching other
Sports other athletes
I notice things and I say to my Jane oh
um
they're under pressure now they're not
going to be doing so well I can see just
because they're at the point of winning
they've not been doing their art long
enough
and now they're starting to falter
because it's coming so crucial to them
and she'll say well I can't see anything
wrong I think he'll be okay
oh she'll be okay it doesn't really
matter
the
the human being what gender
but
they may not change but they start to
falter
and I've been doing this for years and
it's in all sports
but what's what this film about is I'm
watching the tennis a lot of people like
the tennis a lot of people don't like
tennis
but I like to watch the main events
perhaps the Australian Open The French
Open
and in this case it's come about the
yearly event of the Wimbledon you K
tennis Championship one class
and I was looking and making the same
observations this week
and Jane said but how can you say that
you said that he'd
um
he was winning he was doing so well and
then when it comes to the tire boy they
got so close when it comes with a tie
break
um the person who was winning and doing
so well
he start to lose it and completely lost
the tie bike
and
once they get
six each
they have to go to the Thai bike and
then
he lose the one of them loses the whole
of those six
games
in one
Thai bite
and it's because
I said the other person's been doing it
a lot longer and even though they'll
have stress and concern they won't
they'll they'll be they'll have the
depth they'll have the knowledge from
all those years experience
and the younger person who's not been
training so long
they will start to want it so badly that
their quality deteriorates
and to me
this is a big factor that we must try to
overcome in Aikido
so when I look around the world
and think to myself
oh that person's good
it they may not
someone will say to me but they're not
doing our style
so I'm not looking at our style
I'm looking at the person
I'll conclude this in the second half of
the film
thank you for being with me this